[Musique]
et vous lui avez parlé quand pour la
dernière fois ça fait quelques semaines
grand mère maman elle m'a appelé il ya
quelques semaines je crois qu'elle avait
peur elle avait l'impression que
quelqu'un voulait rentrer chez elle
là
dt tu te souviens tu étais maman
j'imagine que je suis sorti c'est quoi
ça elle était dans la propriété quand et
grands parents en ont hérité
apparemment il n'avait pas toute sa tête
tu vas pas la mettre à l'asile quand
même elle peut plus vivre tout seul
maintenant ça elle a besoin d'être
surveillés
tout va bien grand mère voyez que c'est
par là qu'il était mon trip qui celui
qui rentrait dans la maison
maman qu'est ce qu'il ya il est là il
est sous mon lit n'ya rien ce temps les
mamans vérifie pour moi
[Musique]
je suis là pour t'aider
je te vois tu sais
[Musique]
cette maison nous semble étrangère
non
[Musique]
le charmant
ap
il
oui
[Musique]
jeudi christine
côté sport
le saint amour
week-end
comment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si jamais un jour ton vieux bourg qui
pensent par dessus la barrière
[Musique]
il voudrait que sa petite bille qui
était continue dans le monde heureux
mais qu'à poursuivre ce qu'on a brassé
tous les deux ensemble
un diamant brut
j'ai presque maquette plus aérée à
remettre tout le monde à terre mais si
maintenant un moment que nous attendons
tous avec impatience et la révélation
québec de piano voici
j'étais grand retour je le sais qu'il va
les atteindre faut que je voie aux
choses qui sortent de voulu proposer un
cachet question dation mieux quand même
ce trafic à effectuer
tu veux
que le feu
m
foutu d'éleveurs manami tombeur d'abord
puis sur que lui c'est pareil tu avais
pas compris que pour ma petite princesse
stock princes qui lui faut prévient
bruno bronzé quatre fois sans faute deux
fois et demi son âge et qui deux fois
divorcé il ya beau avoir le monde entier
dans la salle c'est pour lui que je
chante pas ma vie mais accord cette
folie là on va pas la faire car moi
qu'un droit à mes yeux mais dis moi que
tu m'aimes pas
[Musique]
merci
moby
[Musique]
et comment vont les choses entre jeunes
nettoient
johnatan
salut le boulot s'est bien passé mais je
me sens un peu fatigué ces derniers
temps
bats toi
[Musique]
vous avez tous les deux une vie bien
remplie il me paraît normal que tu te
sentes un peu fatigué mais ne t'inquiète
pas
moi aussi je me suis senti fatigué ces
derniers temps j'ai pas pourquoi
ouais c'est ça vous êtes allé au bar le
rialto à john publie pas un truc où vous
avez bu deux bières en attendant que
votre petite amie finisse un service
petit ami votre petite amie et lena ka
minsk
john c'est la première fois que je te
vois en plein jour on se voit ce soir
pourquoi est ce que tu m'as pas parler
d'elle rien dit car je savais avoir une
copine est contraire au règlement
tu doit la quitter je ne peux pas faire
ça
il va falloir que tu lui parles de nous
deux et si tu ne le fais pas je le ferai
un seul corps pour plusieurs conscience
vous êtes vraiment différent et cela
vous êtes quoi vous
je fréquente son ancien petit ami tu
dois le dire à john qu'est ce que tu
fais si tu m'explique
je n'aime pas quand vous êtes fâchés
tous les deux c'est important tu sais
que c'est grave
tu dois faire quelque chose je pensais
que tu étais celui qui s'épanouissait
mais j'avais tort il faut que je te dise
quelque chose je suis amoureux
joe natale
[Musique]
oh
je crois qu'il peut vraiment décidé de
démolir chassés par les jeux le viol aux
états unis
mon cousin il habite là-bas toujours pas
l'intérêt de partir au bout du monde
[Musique]
fondée congo face à l'aik puis la sécu
si tout est nickel ils pourront pas là
d'esprit comme ça à cause d'un censeur
j'ai très bien ce que je fais
lorsque l'un des plus toxiques une
facture pour 30 ans pour réparer la cité
c'est pour nous en plus aguerris forever
vertige gagarine il n'a pas le parti
à lloris fautif mère et moi détruire la
cité
[Musique]
dimanche
oh
la pétanque pour en face
[Musique]
oh
brest avec moi tu peux rester
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
oh
c'est quoi ton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la nuit
et
[Musique]
au total
valentine's day
[Musique]